well let's get into it because we got a
little we're rolling unlimited yeah we
got limited time here yeah so let's just
zoom i thought you pushed her well an
extra 15 minutes but yeah all right yeah
you know uh
look we got to talk about rob's parking
job this morning because it was
fantastic
when you pull into a garage by the way
when i pulled in it was the only car in
the garage
so when i pulled on there was no cars
there and i was like oh my god i got to
do this as quickly as possible and get
out of the garage because it won't be
funny if they pull yeah it's very funny
so
for listener at home rob uh
parked sideways taking up two spots like
diagonally yeah diagonally sideways
would have been incredible yeah yeah
and specifically the spots that are
labeled uh charlie and glenn he took our
spots and uh double parked and boy it
made my morning it made my day did it i
had the exact opposite reaction i was
just i was like this is so [ __ ]
annoying i almost
went to rob spot and did the same thing
over there
was to take out something i had nowhere
to go you know to park and i was like ah
no it's fine just the one i would have
come in furious i know i know seriously
and so i let it be until i let it be
there is there is a world in which uh
maybe i would have found that funny uh
and for some reason this morning and i
wasn't not in a bad mood or anything i
wasn't in a bad mood when i showed up
but for some reason i didn't find it
funny i i recognize that it is funny i
will say that
but it's like one of those it's one of
those jokes where it's like it's like
it's like somebody pushes you in the
pool you know everybody thinks that's
[ __ ] funny but it's like you just
push me in the pool you [ __ ]
push me in the [ __ ] pool fully
clothed you know what i mean like
yeah
i need to [ __ ] change my attitude or
something i saw actually yeah i was jill
and i were were in mexico and we were at
a hotel and we were hanging out by the
pool just chilling
and there was some like wedding party
that was there and um and uh
there was one morning where
uh you know it was like a group of
people in their 30s and this one girl
pushed her girlfriend into the pool she
was fully clothed and i was like oh this
will be interesting i wonder how she's
going to react she's she just laughed
yeah she laughed and she just was like
well i guess this is a swimming dress
now and everybody else laughed and then
she just kept swimming yeah and i was
like
man i wish i could be that person you
gotta know the audience i know but you
gotta know the audience i know i would
never do that to you but i have like
four friends i would do that to our
friend matt manick for example right
yeah like you could throw him into the
middle of the ocean off of a off of a a
cruise liner and he would think it was
funny right and i don't and i know that
i would not ever do that to you because
you wouldn't find it funny but this
morning i knew for a fact that charlie
would find it funny and yeah you i
thought 50 50. uh 50 50 chance yeah well
this is the problem with the comedy
right not all jokes are for everybody
and uh you know there's a lot of uh
there might be people out there that
that can never find parking that are
finding this conversation really
upsetting
because they're like i'm that person you
know for for most of us parking is very
difficult new [ __ ] have a
garage with just parks galore and you
think it's it's fun to park your car
however you want you're not being
sensitive to me
well no there are plenty of spots in
that garage i think yeah but they're not
they're not
they're bad spots they're not good spots
so that's that's part of it too but also
like so now you
because i'm like i'm not going to have
somebody jammed in next to me so i just
took up two spots yeah i took up two
spots too
okay yeah it happens well this actually
has everything to do with this
crazy thing that happened
last night and i wanted to bring it up
to you because i was thinking wow this
is kind of falls in line that's quite a
build up yeah exactly with like the this
parking thing that is like so stupid but
also uh but but it's something like
people have to deal with on an everyday
basis and i don't know if i did the
right thing
but
i
i and i want to get counsel i want to
hear your i want to hear everybody's
point of view i would love to hear
megan's point of view as well because i
want to figure out how
i can how i can move forward should a a
something like this happen again
i will say it was the closest
that i came to a physical fist fight in
ten years
okay i'm so excited about this all right
let's get into it i was
we were
milliseconds away when did this happen
so last night last night okay okay so
did you and katelyn
[Music]
caitlyn
left on saturday morning okay to go
shoot a movie in canada right leaving me
solely in charge of the safety of our
boys wow well i'm going to tell you well
there's uh we don't have anybody
helping or anything like that over
certainly over the weekend
so it's just the three of us you know
doing our doing our thing and we had
this plan to go
to dinner
to in-n-out burger which is like an
exciting thing to go you know every
sunday night you're taking the kids to a
burger joint yeah and you're going to
get there's a lot of people that are
listening to this i've never heard of in
and out burger i've never heard about i
think most people have heard it it's a
california burger chain it's very good
yeah it's pretty good it's higher it's a
higher quality yes and people love it
they love it yeah we are not sponsored
by in and out so let's know we are no
that's not kids it's not my kids love it
let's not go crazy so
now this one is heart of what of
westwood okay right when for westwood
people uh it's that's where ucla is yeah
yeah i like college nice area it's a
college okay okay college burger joint
so we pull up it's like 5 30 but now
it's daylight savings so it's night time
yeah the kids are jazzed axel's sitting
in the front seat he's 11. leo's in the
back seat he's
and we
we
pull up and we realize oh as in and out
always is there's a line of cars yeah
and so the way that it's set up is that
you have to go around the block
basically so you gotta i see that
there's a line of cars i'm like the kids
have been looking forward to it all day
we're just going to sit down guys you
want to sit in the line they said yes so
i go around the block and i pull i pull
and i'm probably like the 15th car so
we're going to sit here for 30 minutes
no no no no in and outs they got it down
to us they're trying to get you in and
out
they are turning they're enough they're
trying to get they're pretty fast
sorry i would say but you're definitely
in for a little bit of a wait absolutely
and it did turn out to be about 30
almost 30 it's like 25 minutes which i
would never normally do but my kids were
super excited yeah so
we're waiting there we're like four
minutes into it we're listening to in
the height soundtrack we're singing
along we're having a blast
it's all fun it's
so at one point we're in this line
and a car and i [ __ ] you not you could
not have scripted this better it was a
rolls-royce oh man a [ __ ] giant rolls
royce
and it this guy decides he's coming the
opposite direction
so he just turns into the line right
right at me like trying to get in
between me and the car that's in front
of me but i think well there's no
way he's trying to get in the line
because now there's like 10 cars behind
me oh oh he wow yeah yeah yeah yeah so
right so
he was out of gray poupon and there was
an emergency
yeah
that's a real thing people in royal
voices they [ __ ] love that mustache
hey that put on so then i think this
guy's probably just trying to do like a
u-turn he's trying to like turn around
turn around and then continue down the
the street right there's no way somebody
could be there it's not even on your
radar because you're like no it's so
outrageous
yeah yeah so he so so then i realized
like oh he's not backing up to complete
the
the three-point turn he's actually
thinking he's going to get in between us
right can i ask a sorry a detailed
question yes did he use his blinker
i was no i doubt it i doubt it because
this kind of person is not using
blinkers he does not well this is the
thing like i have a real pro well
whatever i i just if he had his blinker
on i'd be like
all right
but no blinker you don't get in well you
don't get in i don't let anybody in who
doesn't use their blinker by the way
i'm furious
it wasn't like it wasn't like oh my god
i messed up
i'm so sorry or i'm in a rush or can i
this guy just pulls a [ __ ] rolls
royce i deserve this yeah i deserve that
okay
okay
so
once i then the on the traffic starts
piling up because he's blocking charges
oh my god
and then i and then i roll down the
window i go are you trying to turn
around and he goes
back up back up and i said i'm sorry are
you talking to me and he goes
he let me in
and i said what he goes let me in
oh boy
and i i turned to axe and i have my
children yeah yeah that's tricky that's
tough and i take a deep breath
and i roll down the window and i said
[ __ ] you are not getting you are
not getting in front of me so i don't
know what you're gonna do but you better
do it right now
and he looked at me and i looked at him
and i looked back at my kids and i was
like oh [ __ ] he might get out of his car
right i have to i can't stay in the car
because if i do i don't know what this
guy's going to do i don't know if he's
going to smash the window or whatever
well you know yeah so i grab the key fob
cause i'm like if i get out i got to
lock this door to lock them in
because it's all happening so fast good
job wow that stuff yeah yeah pretty
that's pretty much i also think if i
have the key fob in my hand and if i
have to throw a punch it won't break my
hand i'll it'll you know whatever it'll
make my hand stronger like this is all
happening fast so he
he he i see him start to get out and i
start to get out and then he stops and
then i stop and then all these college
kids are like what the [ __ ] is going on
and then then finally he pulls back in
pulls back in and then he rolls up his
window and he starts looking at his
phone
and i was like and axel's like what's
going on and i was like
uh well i'm just handling something hold
on one second and then i said and then
he was but cars are honking honking
honking the guy's not moving so i said
what are you gonna do
nothing
the car finally pulls up in front of me
so i pull up and the guy gets in
behind me because behind us
i noticed were two young women who were
like clearly like college
age
women who were like terrified of what
was going on right and we're like i'm
not going to get involved with this
[ __ ] lunatic so they let him in
so now
i'm looking in my rearview mirror we're
now in line together
and i keep looking up to see like he's
behind me i'm like is he gonna get out
of the car but i'm like i'm not getting
out of this [ __ ] line we're getting
our cheeseburgers now axel and leo i'm
checking in with them thinking if
they're scared they're so psyched
they're like what are you going to do
what are you going to do i'm like
i don't know but guess what
[ __ ] were getting our
cheeseburgers and they were like yeah
we're listening to in the heights
that's the best part is like you're
rolling the window down it would have
been better if you were listening to
some like like oklahoma or something
yeah i'm a little confused on something
sorry he keeps going i need some clarity
yes so
you're in the line he tried to get in
front of you you called him out yeah and
then he got behind you but now you're
all just like in the line together
correct correct but god i wish when you
rolled your window down you were
listening to like hello dolly
yeah
you know that when what happens it all
becomes like a blur i need a little more
information did you get a good look at
it did he look like a conor mcgregor
kind of yeah so that was what was that
right that's the scariest part to me is
that i wasn't even paying attention to
that yeah i didn't know if there was
four guys in there or one and then i was
like i took a deep breath and was like
thank god there's just like one and i
think he saw
he saw that i was ready to go and he and
and then he wasn't and i was like thank
god and also thank god i don't know who
this guy is why are you driving a
rolls-royce he could be a gangster he
could have a gun i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on
but it turned out he just he's just a
bully [ __ ] so thank god so
now now he's behind me and i keep
looking in my mirror not because i'm
trying to antagonize him but because i'm
wondering like if this guy gets out of
his car
i'm gonna have to do something about it
right and i don't but i'm not going to
leave i'm not going to leave because i
feel like that sends the wrong message
to the kids right now of course the
right but this is let me finish the
story and then i'll go back and ask a
number of questions because i have
because i'm not sure that i handled this
right 100 correctly but i figure okay
now here we are
so
i [ __ ] you not we go to turn the corner
because the line is literally going
around the block it's a blockbuster the
the the in and out and as i go to turn
another car a third party gets involved
okay now this is two guys
and they pull up and they try to jump
jump in and i literally have to like in
front of you in front of me again
at the turn let me ask you another
question here yeah are you leaving an
awkward
because i'm using my hands to display
but
you're saying there's there was no like
odd amount of space between your car and
the car in front of you for some reason
they think you're the car to jump in
brother um it was the way that we were
positioned yeah because of the way we
were positioned oh where you are on the
corner i was making a right turn yeah so
there's only so much and then there's a
walkway and there's college kids
everywhere so you got to leave a little
bit of a space
if you're on a freeway and you've got to
merge at the end whatever you're keeping
track let's see people literally knowing
they're jumping and
let me ask you there's no way from where
you're positioned that it could be
accidental like they couldn't tell that
you're there's absolutely no okay
continue okay it's so 100 clear because
in and out is always there's always like
a line like this right trying to get the
big picture
and then also then also based on on this
person's response these two guys so they
pull up
and then
they like literally they're jerking
their car in towards me and i'm like
what the [ __ ] sorry did they see what
had happened between you and the role
this is nothing they don't know it's
like oh my god
totally unrelated
axel's like what is going on and i was
like i'll tell you what's going on and i
opened the door and got out now i'm now
i'm out of the car yeah and i pointed at
the guy that was driving and i was like
turn this [ __ ] car around right now
and get to the back of the line and then
he stopped pulled up drove around and
went to the back of the line and then i
pulled up and got in the car
and leo was like
you're um you're very upset
and i was like i am very like is
everything okay i'm like everything is
100 fine now meanwhile you you're my
adrenaline is through the roof right but
i'm not gonna let i don't want them to
feel like scared or whatever so i jack
up in the heights because now i'm like
[ __ ] this like now
now now i'm like this is my favorite
part we gotta play we gotta play this
cool so piranha comes on and we're
singing paraguay
i don't [ __ ] know that i've never
now i'm at a ten my kids are having a
blast they're like are you gonna get in
a fight i'm like i don't know
i don't know i keep checking in with
[ __ ] behind me he's not even
looking up past his phone he's moved
past it yes and now there's like all
these kids around watching like what's
going on i hear some guy go is that mac
and i was like hey what's going on like
this is crazy all right i'm like i know
yeah it's a bunch of college kids oh my
god like this is not something i was
like what's going on i just want to get
a hamburger guys
and then they're watching one of their
favorite uh possibly one of their i'm
gonna say it's probably one of their
favorite shows one of their favorite uh
characters on on tv like almost getting
a fight with like multiple people i'm 44
years old in a college town but are you
being filmed yet like this is the stuff
that like the internet's made up
like to see you get your ass kicked on
top of a rolls-royce in front of a
hamburger joint in front of your chamber
store yeah is like the kind of [ __ ] that
goes viral forever
matt gets beat up in front of a
hamburger story 100 percent so this is
all like flashing through my head as
fast as possible because i gotta watch
out for the humiliation the humiliation
of being beaten up in front of your
children yeah
no i know you better win if you're gonna
get out he's gonna win
i think the guy saw that i was like
ready to ready to go and you had justice
on your side yeah
well that's what i believe that's a
powerful ally yeah so then now i'm now
we're in line and we're like ordering
food and i'm just like okay i guess
we're just gonna go through this very
normal process which is exactly what we
did we paid the people we got our
hamburgers and we went home
and then i i sat them down as we were
eating and i was like asking them
questions i'm like how did you feel like
was that like are you scared or were you
nervous and they were like that was
awesome like that that was the scariest
part is like right they were like that
was super um fun
because it was like exciting
and i don't think they were ever scared
but i i don't
know i was like trying to figure out
like okay this is a teaching moment
right but i don't know what the teaching
moment is because i was like look
violence and aggression only leads to
more violence and aggression
however
if you allow people
to just step all over you and like
literally like if you're
the only thing analogous would be like
like if you're in new york city or if
you were anywhere actually and you were
walking and you were standing in a line
like it's starbucks and someone just
literally came up and just
stood there in front of you and then
like pushed you behind
now yes
like
that would just never happen like no
nobody does that no nobody has that
level of like bully in them or
aggression in them if they do they're
probably a lunatic but for some reason
you have these cars and there's like a
degree of separation
but i did notice
that
those guys once they saw that there was
a man on the other end of it and a man
who was seemingly like insane like ready
to go and [ __ ] beat them senseless
they stopped and then they got behind
and then they cut off the women that
were behind us right so like
it was like
to to watch bullies go in and try to
bully then when you stand up to the
bully then they go and bully somebody
else like there's no they're not gonna
learn a lesson yeah maybe they think
twice before they do it again i i don't
know
but i don't know i don't know if i did
the right thing
i don't know what the right thing in
that moment is not putting my kids at
danger is number one and i didn't i
truly did that that's a tough one yeah i
mean i suppose there's a step
between like screaming cussing at the
guy like i suppose there's a step where
you get out of the car and you say
excuse me i'm sorry we're in line please
go back to the back of the line
but if they're unresponsive to that then
you have to take it to the next level i
don't know seems like the rolls-royce
guy was kind of there by the way i don't
think i would have been able to let go
of the guy getting in behind me
yeah yeah i like i would have struggled
with that too i would have been thinking
like do i get out of the car and tell
him to get out of this line because he
cut in front of other people it's not
about me it's about cutting in front of
any of us yes yeah i think that would
have been a hard time with that yeah he
bullied the people behind us now
meanwhile
what i'm what i'm guessing and this is
where i want to check in with meg
because dudes have to navigate this all
the time with other dudes but i haven't
in a long time like not since i was like
younger but women have had to navigate
this for oh millennia dealing with men
like finding themselves in these
situations and i'm sure that these women
were like you know what fine who cares
[ __ ] get in line it's goddamn in and
out burger who cares like are you but
the only thing that i extrapolate from
that decision-making process for that
guy is that he does a version of that
all day long well that's right that's
why he was able to calm down and just go
straight back to his phone he's he's he
bullies all throughout the day and
sometimes he gets away with it and other
times he doesn't doesn't [ __ ] faze me
the way now he's so used to it it's just
normal behavior for him so he just like
he was like ah this guy's not gonna let
me do it [ __ ] it i'm just getting on my
phone yeah pull in front of these girls
yeah
yeah yeah
it was a it was like it was psychotic
almost like
i'm gonna not care about people so much
that i'll block traffic yeah with my
rolls-royce to get in because people
have let me
do this for and then i i physically feel
yeah feel something right now like like
in my my body i can feel fury and and
rage kind of boiling up in there it's in
there i'm like
oddly enough just hearing this
we went to the batting cages a few weeks
ago and i realized i as we were stopping
and starting i realized i had two
aluminum bats in the trunk of the car
because they kept clinking and i was
like there was a point which we were it
was already past the the event and i
kept hearing them clink and the more
that i heard them clink the more i was
like
you know
if things go south i know i have those
bats back there i'm gonna [ __ ]
destroy this guy's car and maybe destroy
him yeah and i'm i truly believe i would
have done it that's
crazy well you wouldn't have right
because
you didn't right so so you do have a
stop it like we i think we all have
those thoughts in those situations where
like i'm gonna go berserk you know
uh you know pull up
jack nicholson pull out the golf club
out of your car and smash the guy's
windows in um
but you had something that stopped it
because you didn't my my children in the
car that's a big one yeah but like if
you were sitting next to me or you were
sitting next to me i think we i would we
would have gotten the first fight maybe
or well he would have he got we were
ready to i was still ready to go and he
he he did not get out which thank god he
didn't because i don't know what would
happen well that's the thing like he
might have had a little gold-plated
pistol that's
like a little marble handle and it gets
you right in the thorax and there you go
you're done you might have been a
[ __ ] mma fighter i have no idea
that's right yeah i know yeah that's the
thing that's that's always the thing
that i think of these days whenever i
get into a situation like that is i'm
just like it's not worth it no it's not
worth it
and the the lesson that i'm teaching my
kids
i i i look i mean if you're asking what
is the right thing to do
um i i mean i you know not that i'm any
authority on this but i think the right
thing to do in that situation is to just
let them in
and i'll tell you why because it's not
worth putting yourself and your kids in
danger
to teach them the lesson of you
shouldn't allow someone to push you
around you know what i mean because like
if somebody's if somebody uh holds you
at gunpoint and says give me your money
you don't go
no because i would be teaching you the
wrong lesson yeah you give them the
[ __ ] money because you don't want to
get shot um
yeah now that being said
i think i would have done the exact same
thing you did because i
have uh
rage inside me and i don't know why
but things that are unjust and things
that are unfair i mean this is the whole
this is this is why it ties in with the
whole parking thing right because it's
the whole like
you know walking
by the way
this is what ties into the whole show
this is what the whole our whole show is
for me
is lampooning
the type of behavior that comes from
people who think that they deserve
better than everybody else in the world
you know what i mean in that they could
they should just be able to get whatever
they want and do whatever they want
regardless of the consequences that it
has on other people uh that's that that
that's something that is so infuriating
to me yeah that it that's what i channel
into the show i do believe in
in some sort of karma right like if you
let that that guy in he gets his
hamburger first pulls out and gets
t-boned right the second he's like you
know like like i do think there is
there's some truth to that sometimes in
the world i'll i'll give you an example
almost the same exact scenario
i was in high school i went to this
really uh fancy private high school
i commuted there you know because it was
in my town
but lots of kids lived there and boarded
there and they were super rich kids and
i was not a rich kid and it was a very
different sort of thing was your parent
were your parents the music teachers
there or no no i
i just did an interview my parents said
you know this is a really good school
really close to us you should just go to
the interview process and maybe get
financial aid and go
and i convinced them that i was
intelligent and and had the capacity to
learn which was not the case how did you
do that uh i'm good
i'm an actor he's charismatic
yeah yeah yeah um but
thomas bricks um but uh so
so i'm in line uh in the food line and
there's there's this kid and i'm gonna
call i'm gonna call his name out right i
can't get sued here the kid's name was
paul
and he was probably a senior and i was
maybe a sophomore or something and he
was twice my size and um
and he was a cool kid and i think he
wanted to be an actor he was like the
actor guy
and he like
cut in front of uh
um
me and a couple other guys and
just like blatantly cutting the line and
and you know same sort of thing you know
my like teenage furious like hey man you
can't do that
um
you know and just like get go in the
back of the line
so he comes he gets right in my face
and it's like what are you gonna do
make a move throw the first punch he's
like you knocked me out one punch uh and
i'm like
the school had really strict fighting
policy yeah i was like i can't get
expelled you know my parents have put
everything for me to be here like this
[ __ ] rich kid probably bounced from
school to school to school school
and so i i didn't do anything back down
right he goes in line gets his food uh
then throughout the rest of the year
before he graduates he's he
constantly calling me out trying to
bully me trying to pick fi lure me into
a fight and i never [ __ ] do it
well
i know i know this about the kid he
really wanted to be an actor
well guess who's a [ __ ] actor
now you know what i mean so so [ __ ] you
paul
look him up on instagram and i did like
he didn't do [ __ ]
so
so
you know what sometimes what goes around
comes around i'm just saying yeah
there's a there's like well it's also
like that guy that guy right rolls royce
guy he's miserable
so because only a miserable person will
do something like that
i did think that for years to the point
where i was like i shouldn't even i even
feel bad calling him out right now but
like being like [ __ ] that kids probably
[ __ ] had shitty parents at home send
them away right well that's true that's
true right you don't know what hit you
don't know what led to that in him that
is a good point i know but sometimes
some people maybe are just monsters you
know like uh well there's there's
there's true sociopaths but i think most
of the time that behavior comes from
being mistreated themselves of course
and you can look at it that way so like
i do think i mean i really do think that
the right thing to do is to go you know
what this guy is is miserable
and he's angry and he thinks he deserves
everything and walking around the world
feeling entitled to whatever you want in
any given moment is actually kind of a
a burden it's difficult
um
and it makes people into bullies and
he's the kind of guy that thinks he's
got to drive a rolls-royce so that
people like right yeah
well i think yes yes i mean who wants a
rolls-royce first of all that is the
biggest ugliest clunkiest
stupidest car nobody maybe if someone
drives you in your rolls-royce if you
sit in the back it's a butler's car we
saw one the other day
we saw one the other day and it was it
was actually really nice and joel's like
that's really you know it's nice but
like it looks like it's like a butler's
car you know what i mean like you drive
one of those yourself you have a guy
drive you and even and then then that's
dude maybe he was a butler and he gets
yelled at all day by the guy he drives
around and he's like god damn it i'm
just and the guy's like if you don't
give me my hammer by three o'clock you
know what i mean he's like i gotta
[ __ ] just cut in this line he's like
oh this guy's furious at me all right
i'll get behind him and he's wearing it
was he wearing a top hat and tails
i was open to that i was literally like
what what's going on what are you what
are you doing and if he was like i'm so
sorry man i'm late and i just i gotta
eat and then i gotta go pick up my boss
i'd have been like oh okay this is yeah
no no right right he was like he was
like let me in
and i and i i
i just i went to it i picked up the key
fob and opened the door like i was like
no that's not gonna happen
and
i would do it yeah how often like you
where you think oh no what i'm doing is
keeping everybody safe in my mind even
though i knew i wasn't but i'm out of
ten and i'm like no i'm keeping my kids
safe because i'm teaching them a lesson
i'm keeping the whole this whole area
safe
i'm escalating something into potential
violence that's right right as opposed
to just going to your point yeah go
ahead go go ahead and go in the fact
that it happened again
which is even crazier
is like oh this is a thing that happens
here every day right people stand in
line sit and or they drive around online
and then other dudes there's no [ __ ]
way a woman has ever done this just like
cut in and been like now i'm going i i
don't know
similar response it just wouldn't have
been physically wrong yes that same yeah
exactly right you would have gone unless
she said oh my god i'm so sorry can i
just get in here i need to go do
something it was more like
her attitude was like let me in [ __ ]
which is what he was saying i'd have
been like no [ __ ]
yeah for sure for sure which is totally
appropriate yeah i mean i you know and
then
and then
later on i told the 80 year old woman to
go [ __ ] herself once yeah and sometimes
they they need to everybody needs to go
[ __ ] themselves from cognitive i i did
and her daughter was shot yeah
well axel and leo have basically spent
the night and the day saying go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] yourself because that's
what i said to the second
boy oh boy yeah whatever well oddly
enough earlier in the day
now this is not what i'm thinking about
while this is happening but earlier in
the day i have one son who struggles
with giving up power and control he
needs to like have control and power my
other son struggles with
him giving too much of his own power
away and it manifested in a very silly
way but like the one kid always needs
the remote control like always and he
gets to dictate what they want
what what they watch and i'm like we can
both yeah of course everybody with kids
does and like this is great the other
kids got to have the remote control now
because you have to practice first kid
you have to practice
giving up power
and you have to practice taking power in
difficult situations so it was kind of
like manifesting itself in real time
where i was like oh wow
um
youngest son you have to see that like
you can't let people walk all over you
and just because otherwise they'll just
keep cutting in line but to what point
do am i saying to your point glenn
earlier like am i saying actually you
should do that at all costs right that's
dangerous
like you giving up your power isn't like
letting somebody in line in front of you
imagine the news story like you said
charlie like
like i i have so much to lose right now
my life could not be any better and and
it's also not your job to police the
world one hundred you know what i mean
like right
also it affects you more directly that
they're trying to cut in front of you
now if you saw three cars ahead you
probably also would have been irritated
by it but slightly less irritated by it
you know if you saw it four cars behind
but it depends on who i was with like if
i was with my kids i would have let it
go
if i was with like a friend or if i was
alone i think i still would have gotten
out and said something i think
specifically because of who they were
cutting off who they wound up getting in
front of sometimes you don't have
control over it like your lizard brain
takes over and your testosterone
through the roof and then you're like
i'm i'm also i'm equally out of control
here that's where i was all the way even
through the entire process because i'm
now the guy's behind me and i don't know
if he's getting out i don't know who's
texting by the way at one point i was
like maybe he's texting somebody to come
meet him there yeah yeah and like we
have access to the trunk and there was a
part of me that wanted to be like hey
kids grab the bats now just in case but
i don't want to freak them out yeah but
i i'm now i'm thinking like oh i can get
to the bats because i'm stuck now
between the car in front of me in the
car in the back of me if this guy's
texting his friends to come over here
okay let's we got to be ready to rock so
i'm like i gotta get to the baseball
bats what would you do 44 year old actor
i should not be in situations where i'm
like considering getting a baseball bat
to fight a guy in a rolls royce in an in
and out burger in westwood california
what would you do would you do double
bats like a bat in each hand or what
like what
that would be like my bat style no i
would think i would go one double bats
you just don't have the strength and
speed that you have with the single bat
double unless you're trained in it the
guy comes out
well
i don't have my swords but i do have
these two bats you know what i mean like
then maybe yeah but i i think if you're
not trained in it you want to get i
think i go single bat and then i hand
the other one to the to axel and i'm
like i don't know where this is headed
man yeah but you gotta bat we're gonna
go back-to-back
yeah
you know what i mean you you and axel
back to back right just fighting but
i'll tell you what i think i think to
your question if you had grabbed a bat
and gone berserk and started smashing
the guy's headlights in or whatever it
is even if nothing happened
it would it it probably would have
stayed in your children's memory that's
right and it probably would have
created pathways towards violence for
them that
made it more accessible i don't know i'm
not guessing i'm guessing i agree but
that that would not that would have been
an act of uh offense not an act of
defense what i was saying was i was
suggesting was like it would be an
active defense but it's literally like
metaphorically and physically like
cavemen holding clubs it's like what i
got to i was like i'm gonna hold a club
like a [ __ ]
like a caveman get my hamburger
to get my hamburger before you get your
hammer i'll give my hamburger
[Laughter]
and you don't get hamburger i get a
hamburger
you know come on
yeah and like i was like i'm gonna be up
all night because i i'm like the worst
dad ever and as i'm like reading to my
kids and tell them good night they're
like that was awesome and i'm like okay
great like go to bed and then i was like
i'm not gonna be able to sleep and then
i slept like a [ __ ] baby really yeah
you thought your adrenaline was gonna
keep you up
yeah like i was putting my children
in danger right but then i don't know i
think my adrenaline just dumped and i
just fell so so you went through that
last night and then you came to work
this morning and you thought you know
would be a funny joke yeah i'm gonna
take up two parking spots
yeah well i feel like it's a joke
which is the injustice of it all yeah
like if somebody actually parked that
way if somebody actually parked that way
we would all be very upset if someone
was just like
yeah this is rob's sense of humor though
right i mean you know one of your
favorite jokes is you know somebody
texts like i'll text you something very
sincere
you know where i'm like hey man
i really appreciate uh you know you
helping out on set yes or whatever like
you know it's like a very sincere
heartfelt text
and rob will text back
[ __ ] you
um yeah well like and that that's your
sense of humor we've
it's a great joke it's a great joke
because it hurts a little bit yeah it
hurts a little bit and you know that was
i have to say like when when you and i
first met
um
because that's always been your sense of
humor and i've always had a strange
sense of humor and
i think it was in there to to sort of
have that kind of thing but
i
you you would make jokes and do [ __ ]
like that when you and i first met
to the point where i was like i don't
know if i like this guy
i like because i i was like i wasn't
quite sure
i was pretty sure that it was a i knew
it was a joke i knew it was a joke but i
was like how deep is this darkness is
this like a is this like a darkness you
know what i mean that that's there and
he's learned how to channel it or is
this like a dark guy who's gonna bring
me down if this is a northeast thing but
i find you and your buddies
and like that sense of humor to me is
very familiar from new england i find it
comforting yeah whereas when i started
dating mary elizabeth and she grew up in
the south and then was in texas and then
out here um
that she
was less open to to like
yeah we don't do that [ __ ] in the south
yeah like we don't make jokes like that
like ribbing or or like you know
which and then i kind of i sort of grew
out of it in a way where i was like yeah
i guess it probably is
better not to like insult someone or
through humor or whatever but
i don't know yet well it's a different
thing again it's knowing your audience
and depending on knowing what you're
talking about and recognizing like oh
they don't take this the way that i'm
intending it and that that's not their
responsibility that's my responsibility
to make sure that i'm but i i i think
it's i hope that it's tempered like
those kinds of jokes are also tempered
by and maybe this is why we we became
friends like it's not that i'm
deflecting like actual
emotion like we have very
yeah we have very involved emotional
emotionally complex conversations and
always always yeah and then every once
in a while we think like oh well that's
our rapport and then we'll text
something about like hey charlie you did
a great job yesterday like i really miss
like shooting with you and you're like
one of the funniest people on planet
earth and then he'll respond [ __ ] you
it's just fun
it stings just a little bit because you
just said something like truly so you
were like you know what i'm feeling
something and i'm going to express this
to my friend and then your friend just
texts back [ __ ] you yes
but it always stings a little yeah it
stings a little bit that's what makes it
funny it's in a good way it does
i i feel bad as we
several times you said i really want to
get megan's take on this yeah and we've
not and i mean she doesn't want a
student i know you're avoiding the the
mic but i would appreciate if we just
got your two cents on it yes if it's if
it's
because we can always do like a charlie
brown thing on your voice so that we
can't really
what i'd like to hear from your point of
view because
it i really did feel like
two men a bunch of men like all men
causing abject chaos
and and and i was like oh god this is i
want to feel i want to hear a female
point of view
do you mind uh do you want to hop on one
of these mics real quick i'll pass you
over to them
okay you're gonna all right um
i mean i don't know what you want my
take to be this is unprecedented by the
way this is unprecedented finally i
gotta speak on this thing i'll move over
close to rob so we can share this mic i
would probably just let the person in as
glenn said i would be pissed about it
but
i would be like i'm not gonna
get enforce this what if he doesn't
listen what if it was another woman
if it was another woman i would probably
roll down my window and be like hey
there's a line and if she was like [ __ ]
you let me in i'd be
like
i i'd probably just let it happen
because like i don't know i'm not gonna
fight that woman right and like also my
i don't start thinking about protecting
everyone in the line because protecting
them from what like that seems like a
big leap for you to jump to
um what about the option of like
literally just
like
just keeping pull like pulling so far it
could like that's what i would do i
would pull so close to the person in
front of me that there was no [ __ ]
way they could ever get in yeah and just
and just keep that distance between me
and the car in front of me you know and
be like you want to hit my car [ __ ]
hit it let's do it i would want to
demand i got money let's [ __ ] do that
what are you doing man so i want to get
in like it was a line you know and then
i'm like why do you think this is okay
yeah right right ask for an explanation
explain yourself i would not have the
emotional response that you did to that
situation i'd be like annoyed because i
keep hate people that don't follow the
rules but no i wouldn't have ever gotten
out but i don't think you're like a bad
person for having done that i mean you
didn't
you didn't
actually hit the guy so i don't know
there's something about knowing that
that guy walks around the rolls-royce
makes it worse the rolls-royce makes it
worse and then the fact that then the
fact that there were two guys later in
whatever car they were driving now there
was two of them
and the fact that they were they also
backed down
right and i was like these guys are such
[ __ ] they're just bullies they're
just bullies and sometimes i don't know
like i don't know what you do with how
do i teach my kid that you should you
should always walk away from bullies
sometimes you you shouldn't
yeah sometimes you should call the bully
out yeah yeah and sometimes you might
take a nap like take a beating and that
sucks but the truth is that like the
bully is not going to come back after
you again they're just not
i'm sure he will if he beat you up yeah
you'd be like i can beat this guy up i
got this guy that was never my
experience
i mean because because the bully wants
to go after the person that they know
they is not going to give him least
amount of trouble right right you know
what i mean so it's like i got to beat
this guy up again
you know i mean like at a certain point
i look sad
yeah i mean i don't know like i thought
you introduced me to eckhart tolle
um and
um you know i i think about that and and
like i feel like i do feel like though
the the proper response is
it's not my job to police the world some
people are just miserable
and if this guy really needs to get in
front of me
then you know if he really needs to cut
the line then you know it's like i'm not
going to teach him a lesson yeah he's
not going to learn anything today if
anything he's going to become more
entrenched in in in his feelings and
thoughts
and um and i would be putting myself and
my kids in danger
now again this you know this is this is
th this is coming from somebody who i
again i think i probably would have done
this the exact same thing that you did
like truly but i'm analyzing it and i'm
like it's not i don't think it i really
don't think it's the right thing to do
and i think you set your kids down and
you go because i've always told my kids
i'm like
the only time you should ever get in a
fight is if you can't run
if you can't run and the reason is
because sure you know whatever lesson
you think you might be teaching that
other person by getting in a physical
altercation with them is not it's not
first of all you're not going to teach
them anything and secondly
uh
you might end up in the hospital you
could end up with a permanent a you know
permanent injury of some kind you know
people people get in fist fights and
it's like sometimes it's a it it you
know it's you got a couple bruises and
cuts and it's no big deal other times
you get punched in the eye and you lose
vision in that eye or you kill somebody
or you kill somebody or or you hit
somebody so hard they hit their head on
the concrete and that person [ __ ]
dies it's not worth it no of course not
and it's always in reflection that you
can kind of come to terms with that it's
like when in the heat of the moment and
people i think oftentimes don't realize
like how quickly those things happen and
how you're making decisions based on
instinct and it's like within 35 seconds
it was it was over but you probably can
condition your instincts right whereas
you've had
you know uh
you've had a childhood and and you know
adolescence whatever where where
you
created some pathways for that this is
how you resolve some of these issues
right so you've learned that sometimes
that works right sometimes physical
conflicts
yeah i don't know i don't say they give
you what you want but sometimes that's a
way
through something some other kid
you know uh
obviously that's never been the option
for them so
they didn't create those pathways
towards like okay this is a place my
brain will go my brain will always go
towards make sure i don't get hurt first
or whatever well i definitely have the
luxury of having zero violence in my
household like my fa i never got hit i
never got spanked i never got any of
that so like i don't think i have a
propensity for for violence meaning like
like you said where jack nicholson got
out of the car and just actually took
the the golf club and smashed the guy's
windows i didn't take it that far right
and that makes me feel good meaning like
my insurance you never start taking me
there you never got the spoon the wooden
spoon no or the belt we never got
anything you got a spoon and a belt no i
never got a belt no no no no mom mom got
me with the wooden spoon a couple times
but i think she felt so bad about that
maybe like three or four times and then
i think she should get you on the hand
on the end on the butt on the booty it
was a wood i remember she had a wooden
spoon that had holes in it it's like i
guess so you could you know get the air
you could get you get the airflow so it
actually moves faster yeah i'm not sure
why is that why she picked that spoon
you think or she wanted to turn my ass
into swiss cheese yeah
i don't know but uh she got me with the
wooden spoon a couple times i think she
felt [ __ ] really bad about it and
never did it again though
yeah that's that's sorry it's a form of
violence that kind of [ __ ] yeah i know a
lot of people spank their kids and
it's fun still
well i know
yeah but i but i think i'm lucky that i
never had that in my life and so maybe
that's the difference but and i'm sure
that i'll bet you that guy in the
rolls-royce and the other two they just
had it's just a piece of [ __ ] his pants
are pieces of [ __ ] and so he's a piece
of [ __ ] yeah or maybe i wish maybe
they're not his life maybe they're not
that's the other thing sometimes they're
not at all
they're not at all what pieces of [ __ ]
like there are plenty of kids and he's
just horrible yeah bad eggs great
parents right right that happens too man
i know anyway that's crazy man crazy
that's crazy and i have to have a
follow-up conversation
uh you should today yeah you know
yeah for sure i think you got to stay on
that one and yeah
make sure it gets processed the correct
way yeah
and if you're out there rolls royce guy
uh you know you're listening maybe
you're a fan of sonny i i don't know
maybe that's why you decided to check
out because you were like oh i don't
wanna i don't wanna beat this guy up he
makes me laugh yeah
i'll let him live maybe like i killed
too many people all right today i'll let
this i'm gonna let him go
it crossed my mind i killed a man for
this rolls royce yeah i think he's like
mine this guy actually has more
discipline than i do maybe he's like a
hired like maybe he is someone's driver
and he's like like a killer i don't know
you never know
but i'm not thinking that in the moment
i'm at a 10. yeah
anyway yeah
yeah well i don't think we're gonna get
to this episode that's okay i think this
is just a i think this is just a side
episode of the podcast where we you know
yeah sometimes you just got to talk
about other things you know yeah okay
all right well i'll i'll let you know
how the conversation goes with the kids
or offline maybe that's just good for
one episode i think
oh i don't know maybe we could we could
do a follow-up next time okay just to
see who knows but um
is there something funny that somebody
wants to say to entertain or are we just
going to talk at these people
well i mean i mean
there was a lot of fun there i'd say a
44 year old man getting almost into a
fist fight in the in and out uh parking
lot
for the sake of who gets the hamburgers
first
definitely the thought of math
definitely the thought of matt getting
beat up in front of a hamburger story in
front of his kids it's very funny in
front of his children
yeah it could have happened it could
have very easily happened it's just
funny when i was younger like i didn't
think about the consequences of getting
in a fight like i would get i never go i
didn't get in that many fights i got a
few fist fights and nothing really ever
that bad happened as a result but uh
you know now i think about it i'm like
ah don't break my hand or like you know
what i mean i'm gonna [ __ ] tweak my
back i'm gonna throw my back out it's
just not worth it you know i mean i'm
like or or this guy's a psycho he knows
mma and and you know
i just think i just think i can sort of
like
usually i think i can psycho eyes my way
out of most of those like that has
gotten me out of most physical
altercations psycho psycho-eyes
no really i mean like because i because
i do because i get so
furious i get so enraged that the
impression i give is that i will [ __ ]
kill you
i will [ __ ] kill you
uh and i've felt that
for me yeah well i mean it can be in a
comedic sense that's what we talked
about yeah yeah yeah it's so funny yeah
we all have that fire inside like i you
know i think i could go pretty psychotic
if i had to yeah oh definitely yeah i
know you got it in you dangerous
and dangerous man charlie day's a
dangerous man yeah that was just crazy
charlie dangerous he's got a banana on
his shirt that's that's all right i
don't know that's all right well god
bless you guys thank you for hearing me
out and um hey rob yeah [ __ ] you
yeah hey rob really
in all seriousness
no but in all seriousness when you're
when you're talking about your kid now
i'm just kidding [ __ ] you
[Music]
you